luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto
it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh punch
show joining me today as you can see is the
president and co-founder of silica i'm rit
kumar i'm rick welcome to the show how are you
thank you very much for inviting me over yeah
i'm doing good yourself you okay i'm doing good
yeah it's good to chat to you i think the last
time we spoke was maybe back in september 2019
in london before covid i think that's when it
was right indeed you know a lot of things have
happened since since that meet-up i guess um you
know in the world and of course in silica as well
oh yeah absolutely that's right before the good
old pandemic kicked off but before we jump in
um i do want to let everybody know that this
is powered by um icon plus capital they're a vc
firm and it is sponsored by block five so they
offer really incredible interest rates really
competitive interest rates so i think i've left
a link somewhere so you can you can check that
out if you're interested so let's jump into this
this is going to be a really exciting ama like i
said we haven't spoken in nearly two years so for
me this is going to be really educational um but
i think what would be great would be to start off
sort of understanding a little bit more about you
so tell me your background before you delved
into crypto right so uh my background is in
research so before joining and getting involved
into crypto i was doing scientific research
around security and privacy so essentially i
was looking into ways in which you'd you know
when you download a certain software systems
like let's say antivirus software on a machine
what sort of security and privacy implications
they have on your system so for example
an antivirus may scan your entire file system they
can scan all the photos or files that you may have
and me send some information you know
to the backend vendor so the antivirus
so the idea was to sort of understand
what sort of information they do send
and why they have to send that information so
this was uh you know early 2016 i would say and
around that time you know bitcoin and blockchains
generally speaking were becoming popular
you know in the academic circle yeah people were
starting to see bitcoin as not just a technology
but as a place where you could find and discover
interesting challenging research problems as well
so that was around the time when you know that
peaked my interest as well so i was looking into
i started to feel that okay now i
have to switch over to blockchains
so i moved over to uh to singapore where i
decided to look into the privacy aspects of
blockchains so as you know transact on bitcoin or
ethereum everything that you do becomes public so
anyone can see what happens on those chains there
there were some privacy chains like dash monero
zcash that had come up which can hide some of
the traces of your activity that happens on the
blockchain but my idea was to sort of look into
those uh privacy preserving blockchains and see
whether you actually get that privacy in practice
or not strangely though since the start of monero
and until early 2017 95 to 98 percent of
transactions that ever happened on monero were
not private at all so you could actually decipher
a lot of information from oh wow just by looking
at the blockchain that's not good so you know very
soon afterwards uh you know my advisor who was
at the university back then um he said look
this was good fun let's look at something more
challenging after this and around that time we had
seen crypto kitties happen uh where an icos were
happening so this was you know mid 2017 around
that time and we realized that obviously the these
technologies that we have around bitcoin ethereum
they are really good they're very decentralized
but they're not very scalable and therefore
the idea that we had was to be able to build
a blockchain that could scale and that's how you
know you know silica sort of came into being uh
you know something somewhere some sometime around
mid-2017 so that's kind of my background my story
so if you had to i guess summarize in a really
simplistic way you know what is silica okay so
scalability is obviously um you know at the core
there but if you could summarize it and tell us
a little bit more right so the two when we started
silica we had two key problems i wanted to address
one was of course scalability so we had seen you
know ethereum sort of plug every time there was
an ico you couldn't transact on ethereum gas fees
went really high to a point where if you wanted to
set a transaction worth five dollars you have to
pay a hundred dollars worth of fees so it was it
was around that time that we had started to look
into scalability and the solution that we came
up with uh was called sharding what is called
sharding it's an idea where which is something
that you now see many of the chains sort of
pursuing as well but we were the first ones
to show that you could actually apply this
idea of sharding in a public blockchain like
silica so um that was kind of our one usb the
second problem that we sort of identified was
this idea where you could have smart contracts
that are so expressive that they invite a lot of
attacks and we have seen that happen every other
week you know we have seen starting from dao for
example when uh you know there was uh you know
the entire ethereum community sort of kind of
got divided into ethereum ethereum classic we
saw parity incident happen we saw very recently
you know some of the hacks are on ed5 it was
very clear to us very in the early days that
uh you can't just wait and watch you need to be
able to build solutions that could prevent if not
eliminate completely at least you know mitigate
some of those hacks that you see on a daily basis
so we decided to collaborate with some of the
academics in uh in london by the way uh so we
had an academic from ucl london and the idea
was to be able to develop a language that could
eliminate some of those hacks from happening in
the future so we decided this we decided to design
a new language that we call cila with the idea
of making the language more resistant to attacks
and at the same time you could actually make it
even more stronger you could even say that look
if you have a contract that holds let's say i
don't know a billion dollars you want to make
sure that no one can come in and steal funds
from that contract no one can freeze that money
and what you need essentially is a mathematical
proof that could say that okay here's a guarantee
and my guarantee is that it you cannot break it
it's a there's a mathematical proof behind it
and languages like cilla um allows you to do that
in a much easier way with solidity even if you try
to do that it's much more complex so the idea was
to be able to design a language that's saved by
design at the same time it gives you some stronger
properties that's very hard to prove so yeah these
are kind of two key areas that you already focus
on scalability and and smart contract safety yeah
i think especially it's interesting actually
to have this conversation now especially given
how much this space has developed since our
initial conversation you know there's other
blockchains out there and we'll talk about that
in terms of competitors you know like cardano
for example also working with smart contracts
um so yeah we're going to go into all of this
and i'm really excited to actually um but i want
to start off with the ama now because there are
some really interesting questions and one of the
first questions actually came through on twitter
um i'm considering whether to try and pronounce
these names but i'm going to put it on pause with
a minute um so our first question is so when is
the bridge finally going to launch on the mainnet
right so um as you know um we and those those
people who are following us um we have been using
polynetwork which is the middleware for bridges
unfortunately middleware got hacked recently
which means that we have to be very
careful about how we use that middleware
polynet has been fixing these issues but it's not
fully open in the sense that they have not fully
opened up their middleware to everyone to use
so they're still you know playing very carefully
and we are basically waiting for them to one
open up at the same time you're also taking other
precautionary measures measures making sure that
you know that incident cannot happen again uh you
know with silica uh community so we're also sort
of sort of hardening our systems to make sure that
those hacks and bugs cannot happen we are also
sort of reaching out to white hat sort of hackers
as well through hacker one and basically throwing
them the code and say okay just go and hack it uh
the difference between hackers and auditors is
that auditors generally try to sort of check
whether your contract follows a certain pattern
checks whether they check whether it follows a
certain security recommendations in some sort
so they have a checklist that you try to go with
well hackers have you know basically
a launch of some sort where they
they go and basically try to hack your system
which is which can sometimes be very productive
because if you want to want to find bugs so we
are doing that at the same time we are literally
you know i think today started to prepare our main
net for an upgrade that upgrade is necessary to be
able to enable polynet so i think in a week's time
we will be able to have um uh all the features
ready to have uh to be on the main it and after
that we are basically waiting for the polly net
uh and some of the hackers to come back to us uh
and once all is done and dusted um there's nothing
left to open up the network for for the bridge
and given what happened with polynetwork how
did that directly affect you in any way can we
hear more about that no actually we didn't because
uh and we were kind of lucky to be honest because
um our bridge was not live yet even if it had been
live then it would have been different story
luckily it was not live and therefore we were
saved in many ways uh which i think we're yeah
it was basically lucky and that's why you know
we have to be careful of uh how to how to employ
that uh once it goes live so we have to make sure
that the system is hardened uh poly network uh
whatever the code changes that they're making
they have to get that code audio test as well so
peck shield for example one of the auditors have
checked some of the code they are also talking to
other auditors they're taking sort of very gradual
approach of releasing polynet to other people
as well so we are sort of following their steps
and at the same time on our end we are making
sure that the contracts that we have written
are safe to use and you know getting other people
to to to to sort of check the code again and again
but basically it's we are very close um it's all
about sort of preparing the mainnet with all the
features and then once uh auditors and once um
these hackers give us some feedback then we could
launch this and once you do launch is the team
working on bringing projects that are currently
you know building on ethereum um to move over to
zil i know during the bull market we massively saw
that happen with um finance smart chain which was
really interesting um you know they really became
kind of like a die rice competitor in some ways so
are you guys looking to kind of do the same thing
right so the first thing that happens is so
buying a smart chain and silica is slightly
different in the sense that binding
smart chain is an evm compatible chain
which means that uh if let's say if you
have a contract that's sitting on a theorem
you could basically copy paste that and put that
one smart changes could still work um silica is
not an evm compatible change it means that it's
uh and for good reasons uh in the sense that you
know we have seen what's happening with solidity
code so we have to be careful about building a
building a safer smart contract language and
making sure that that doesn't happen and replicate
so but what what can happen is obviously once the
bridge is live you'll be able to move assets like
usdt btc eth over to silica and then put that on
zilswap and once uh your assets are swap you can
start earning apy depending on you know the the
total value log that stay on that on that pool
once those assets are over to silica they could
also be used in different d5 products that we
already have on zelika for example uh there's
a pillar protocol that's being built which is
a maker dial like system on silica and you could
use for example btc and eth as or usdt for example
as one of the collaterals or for pillar there
are other assets that are other d5 products that
are being built and i think this is where these
assets can come into play uh to be honest it's
not going to be so straightforward for people
to just move from from ethereum to silica but
there is going to be a little bit of work and and
i feel that that work is worth doing it given all
the hacks that are happening in the d5 and empty
space nft space less so but d5 differently so
so we have to be careful about what you bring you
don't want to bring things that are already buggy
and you have to be careful with that uh and i i
feel that it's it's all about making sure that um
you know when these assets come over we need
to have applications that can use those assets
and that's very critical this is where for
example has a protocol slight pillar will be will
play a key role speaking of pillar um one of the
questions that i've come through which is actually
pretty interesting is somebody is claiming that
the pillar protocol project has gone quiet um so
do you have any updates on that is it still going
to launch well they are quiet only because i think
they are developing so they are quite what's going
on behind the scenes um what i know is that again
this is a this is a project that's not developed
by us it's being developed by committee member and
uh which has given which has received a grant from
us and uh what i know is that they again they are
very careful about uh you know launching this uh
this product making sure that it's safe to you for
people to use so they have done a round of audit
i know that they are uh have literally i think a
couple of days ago i had mentioned in one of the
telegram channels that they have launched and
finished a mechanism where you could use gso which
is our governance token to govern uh decisions
around pillar so for example which collateral
which type of collateral can be used on pillar
and people who who come and use their gcl for for
governance on pillar would also have an incentive
to participate so you would be also be earning a
part of the rewards that comes from pillar which
essentially the interest rate so when you come
and take loan from pillar when you borrow assets
you will have to you know return interest rate
and a portion of that interest rate could go
back to the people who help govern the system so
yes it's fully it's it's working uh you know they
have already launched i think the version three
it's not publicly available to people but they
are working behind the scenes so though it's it's
more like the you know silently working on what's
happening and hopefully they will be able to open
this up uh hopefully very soon to to to the rest
of the community good well at least uh things are
still moving forward which we always like to hear
um okay so i yeah i want i do want to talk about
the competition in the market um and one of the
questions is actually comparing zilliqa to cardano
i know you spoke about this a bit earlier um i'll
read you the question so silica have many more use
cases than cardinal at the moment obviously gibbon
cardano hasn't essentially launched has it so has
a zilliqa team done any research on why zil may
be undervalued in the market compared to cardano
and what measures can be done to overcome this
so i mean would you say that zil is undervalued
in comparison to ada well everything is under
valued ideas you would never say you say
that okay here's a theorem of bitcoin is
it's overvalued you won't see that everything's
gone obviously i do feel that we're undervalued um
but you know um if you look at uh the projects
that existed let's say in early 2017 uh in the top
10 or top 20. many of them don't exist anymore
uh many of them have slid down into oblivion
it's all about making sure that so these these
uh you know market sentiments they keep up and
down you know they keep your ranking or your price
can keep moving up and down there's something that
you cannot control per se what you can control is
is the develop and innovation component so as long
as you keep building interesting stuff as long as
you keep attracting uh more projects and you keep
attracting more users to the platform there's no
reason why your the market can can stay you know
oblivious to what you're building at some point it
will come out and that's happened right you know
many projects that uh have been building uh
quite aggressively over the last couple of years
they didn't exist uh in top ten top 3 today you
know the top 20 of today is very different from
the top 20 that existed a year ago or something
six months ago so that that that will definitely
happen as long as we make sure that a lot of
people actually come and use the platform and
the project that we're building and again we're
very early stage you know it's not just zelika
but i think generally speaking blockchain is a
very early stage of adoption right you look at
and i keep citing this million times and i will
repeat this again but if you look at the number
of token holders that you have out there or
just for ethereum for example there are around
a few hundred million uh 140 million i think
uh ethereum token i didn't know that use is is
actually less than less than a million or around
two million so you can see the gap between number
of token holders the number of users i think it's
important for every blockchain platform to push
for that is to make sure that we can attract
more convert more of these token holders into
actual users of the platform once that happens you
know that network effect that comes with it uh is
something that you can't you know the world has
to recognize the network right you can't skip it
i do want to go back just a little bit um
to focus on the polynetwork hack because
i'm actually reading the questions as they came in
um so this is a pretty interesting question so um
the recent polynetwork incident was pretty scary
i think everyone can agree um you know i guess
it was a good thing that you know that bridge
hadn't launched yet so hypothetically speaking
could the bridge have been written in cilla
and if so would this type of vulnerability
have been more easily spotted or even
prevented yes uh so the short answer is yes uh
if if so but there are two components to it
right so yeah the way bridge works is you
have an ethereum component you have a silica
component so someone who let's say who wants
to move assets from ethereum to silica he has to
send a transaction on the theorem network first
and then this transaction basically
gets relayed to the silica network
and then uh you know there's a smart contract
that comes into play on the zelica site
essentially what happened was on ethereum side
uh there's solidity code and it had a component
that allowed you know the hacker to basically uh
do really nasty stuff if you had replaced that
contract by a very similar looking seller contract
this would not happen you know this attack would
could have been averted but the problem is it's
on ethereum and the theorem is is you know does
not support cellar so you have only solidity so
you don't have much choice there i do and that's
kind of why i believe that there's going to be
you know you will have a point in time somewhere
in the future where many of the genes including
silica for example could be uh sort of multi
vm compatible so you could have you could run
solidity you could run cilla you could run rust
you could run other chain other languages as well
that's where i think some benefit could have come
even though for example um you know we have
other networks like switcho who were using
and polynet they were not affected so not every
chain was affected even though they were using
it uh should not would not have been affected
for sure yes the short answer again is yes if
if solitude contract would have been replaced with
a silla contract uh this attack uh in a hack would
not have happened but again ethereum uh does not
support sellers so it's not it's not possible
so that nuance is there as well okay yeah i think
covering these things is really important i think
that hack took a lot of people by surprise um even
to the point where i actually just read this today
but the news came out yesterday um that i think
the polly network are looking to hire the hacker
i mean he did i mean okay uh again you could you
could probably question the intentions or initial
intentions of the hacker and all that you could
debate about yeah but he definitely um some people
could say look um the contract well this was a
very stupid bug uh you know the developer should
have detected it but it's quite smart to be honest
uh the you know the ability to find some of those
uh nuanced uh you know lanes in the co contracts
and code it's not so straightforward so uh credit
to the hacker to be honest um could great to the
hacker to be able to find the find the bug and i
from what i'm hearing is he has returned the funds
and i guess um you know pollya guys are sort of
trying to see if um if he could be helping out in
different ways so why not again you know turning
from about that great hat to white hat uh it's
not so straightforward but um at least it was
interesting to note that you know he was able
to return the fonts which is which is well yeah
i mean if you can go from black hat to gray hat
to white hat i see no reason i can't go from white
hat to gray hat to black cat i don't know i'd
stay away from it personally um okay so again
we have more comparisons um this is also pretty
interesting so does zilliqa have something to
actually counter the api once gzil minting is over
and then i'll quote i mean 12 is nice but i can
reach almost the same with a stable coin on a few
exchanges which is obviously quite true um i know
ada is around five percent um on the other hand
we can on stake instantly so how's that gonna look
right so uh one is you know comparing a stable
coin with a volatile asset is i don't think it's
it's a fair comparison agreed on because okay sure
a volatile asset can go down but it also could go
up so uh even though you are and the reason why
for example stable coins have a certain api is
because there are for example if you look at block
file you mentioned right block parts and some of
these traditional centralized lending platforms
uh if you compare for example the lending rates on
different assets stable coins comes first so that
could vary from something between five percent up
to 10 15 percent yeah then you have btc and eth
uh and the apy i mean apy the lending rate uh
varies something between three percent two to five
percent and then you go even below on alt coins uh
or erc20s that drops to one percent or even lower
sometimes yeah the reason is simple it's it's
demand because when you think about it right why
stable coins have higher apy generally speaking
it's because they are traders they are market
makers they are institutions who want to borrow
stable coins to be able to you know put that
into work for example a market maker would like
to borrow you know usd or usdc and then use that
to do arbitrage trading on different exchanges
you could you could have institutions borrowing or
hedge funds borrowing usd and usdc to be able to
invest and take positions on different assets like
btc and eth and that's why the api is generally
high on stable coins but then again you don't
have the same upside as for example in investing
in a volatile asset right so even for example
in bitcoin lending if it's three percent you do
have an upside of potential value you know price
increase that you don't get with stable points
now coming back to zil's uh comparison uh of
course this is just to say that you know zelicah
is different for stablecoin and therefore
it's not an apple apples to apple comparison
we do believe that uh 12 in terms
of returns is actually quite high
compared to all staking
providers so if you look at it
many of them uh offer you something between
three percent to up to five percent seven
percent ten percent max so in terms of api it's
actually quite high uh if you add g-cell which
is the governance tokens that we're giving
out alongside staking then i think the api
goes even higher to about 25 percent um so yes
there will be a drop once diesel uh goes down
uh one once diesel emitting is over but i think
you still feel that only 12 is high enough now
uh if you compare uh for example let's say
cardano is mentioned in about five percent
with immediate uh and bonding this is something
that could be possible because there are projects
out there in the silica ecosystem today which
are building a solution where you could bypass
and bonding and that that would be possible
so you could still have 12 percent apy
and be able to unstake immediately through some
of those parties some of those products that are
being built so uh yes i don't think we would be
able to increase that otherwise uh the only way
you could increase apy is by you know minting and
inflating the supply or increasing the inflation
which i think hurts everyone so it's not a good
idea but yeah there will be solution i think that
people are building solutions where you couldn't
bond immediately so just to let everybody know
that i'm reading through the comments now and the
live comments um so you guys are welcome to send
through um any questions we have plenty more to
get through but i'm just taking the time now just
to read through them all so you're all welcome
to yeah add as many questions as you like so
i'm going to keep going forward with this um we're
going to get a little bit more technical now so
the next question is don't you think that there
is a problem with decentralizing validation
though since these nodes are centralized
by the large mining pools each mining pool
manages dozens of nodes so it would be great for
decentralization to find a way to have more nodes
for more users right so uh again it's uh you know
it's a discussion that you know happens uh even
in the bitcoin community and i think ethereum
committee as well so you have i would say in
zilliqa you have two types of uh miners uh one
miners are obviously pool operators like uh easel
like shardpool like russ pool and then you
have a lot of individual miners as well
so it's not that they are not individual
miners so they are individual miners mining
mining silica through the old systems and machines
and so that's that's that's there of course you
know um decentralization is always a spectrum
right you know it's not always black and white and
say okay this is the decentralized this is uh not
decentralized so it's always a spectrum yes um we
could encourage people to be um to be individual
and solo miners but then sometimes the reward and
the and the uh you know the cost that comes out
with it is it's not you know and it's not enough
for people to have solar minus so what people end
up doing essentially so if you have a hardware
and you try to solo mine you won't be making
too much money so what you end up doing is you
end up joining mining pools so even though
mining pool you could consider them as one
single entity they are actually they actually
have a lot of individual miners behind them
so that answers a little bit that that part
the other thing that we have been thinking
internally again it's not something we have
acted upon yet but one idea that we had was
um that we're exploring some time back was
to be able to have mining plus staking as
well in terms of in terms of nodes that validate
transactions so you could for example right now
all the nodes which validate transactions they
come through mining but for example we could
do 30 mining or 70 mining 30 staking nodes that
that will allow more nodes uh which are individual
operators to come on board and and and and start
validating transactions which probably make things
more decentralized but just to give a little bit
more context right uh if you look at some of the
other chains out there which have proof of stake
mechanism none of the chains that out there have
more than let's say a thousand nodes so and i'm
talking about staking nodes so if you think about
having building a network with let's say three
thousand or ten thousand staking nodes that's
not quite possible because they're not enough
stakers out there they're not even people out
there who would like to put run an infrastructure
uh and and you know increase the account to up to
two thousand three thousand the maximum
that i've seen so far is around 900 nodes
but again that's a extreme so uh hitting 900 nodes
with taking it is going to be very challenging
yeah i can't remember who i was having this
conversation with but i feel like i'm suddenly
having deja vu um which is really strange uh this
conversation about you know decentralization comes
you know with more people getting on board
more nodes you know more with more users
you can make this happen essentially um i feel
like i'm having dslv so that's kind of strange but
um yeah it's pretty interesting just off the back
of this mining comment um there is a question
that's just come through now and i'd be interested
to hear your opinion on it um this is a pretty hot
topic in this space right now where people are
talking a lot about green energy and things like
that i wondered if you had any thoughts on this
question mining that's pretty much a statement
mining is very frowned upon in the green community
i wondered if you had any thoughts on that yeah
right so uh there are two sides of the story of
course one is uh you could argue that many of the
uh mining structure is being run by non-renewable
sources yeah uh but there are also initiatives
where many of these miners are actually using
renewable sources as well uh there's also an
argument that you could say that look uh if
bitcoin is uh you know handling this much of
transaction volume on a daily basis if you compare
this with traditional uh you know infrastructures
and banks they actually consume less so there's
that argument as well but let's keep that aside
for a moment i do feel that yes uh there is that
angle and i think many people are working towards
that so and that's kind of why proof is taking
also is coming into into play and you know many
chains out there now use profit stake um which
definitely reduces uh the carbon uh footprint
on the zilliqa side particularly and we we did
understand this problem you know we knew and
reclaimed this problem a long time back that's
kind of why we decided to not use mining in the
way bitcoin and ethereum you know mining works so
in bitcoin ethereum um you have to basically do a
proof of work for every single block right yeah
in zilliqa we don't do that so what we do is we
encourage miners to come in mine for let's say
a minute and this mining when they do when doing
this money for a minute they basically get an
access an entry ticket to the network and once
they have the central ticket they use uh something
called a bfd so byzantine fault orders mechanism
which does not involve mining at all so
it's pure voting mechanism something that
most pos systems use so our mining basically is
utilized let's say once every two thousand blocks
probably speaking uh so roughly every two hours
which reduces the carbon footprint the second
thing that we did was we we used hash and because
we don't use uh proof of work every single block
what you can basically do is you can mine
ethereum or let's say mines and bitcoin and
when this two minute block slot comes in you
come and start mining silica and then go back
so your your hardware basically you can
basically do parallel mining of some sort
so you could mine silica and ethereum in parallel
while only spending a minute of your hardware on
silica that's it so it also makes things much
more efficient okay that's really interesting
yeah no i appreciate you explaining that it's such
a hot topic right now and um you know there's a
lot of misinformation out there um especially
you know when we talk about renewable energy
and and things like that so i think it's really
important to go through through those topics just
moving on um are there any plans for um the zeal
networks be accepted by your partner crypto.com
since there aren't yet other stable coins on the
zilliqa network and this user says i don't like
to pay each fees to use xsgd thank you uh yes
so uh there's there's a plan but i think there
are certain regulation uh regulatory changes
that are happening in in singapore right now
from where execute which is a stable
coin singapore dollar backstable coin
so until that regulatory uh you know uncertainty
are cleared uh i think it might be a little bit
difficult for parties in singapore to to list
those assets but yes it's happening and i think
that might come very soon so we're just going
to keep moving forward um guys please you are
welcome to continue putting questions in the live
chat i am monitoring it so yeah feel free to throw
them in um all right so i'm going to keep moving
forward so we have our next question this one is
from jerome lin so see i will i will name some of
the names um okay so this one says since zilliqa
prides itself to be safe and secure and build
a programming language from the ground up why
are we not doing the same thing for our foundation
d5 exchanges as well as our interoperability
instead of relying on third-party networks to
help us build it because the first thing we
can't build everything right you know yeah it's
like it's like ethereum foundation building uni
swap ethereum foundation building maker diet same
foundation building synthetics ethereum foundation
building curve and and so on so it's it's not
possible realistically speaking what i what we do
however is and so from from our angle essentially
we're a platform right so we we provide the
platform that we encourage in different ways uh
one from through marketing developer workshops
uh as well as funding to encourage other parties
to come and build um and that's why for example we
have seen uh switcho in which uh to whom we gave a
grant long time back and through that partnership
we had we switched was interested in building uh
building a decks uh we for example we gave grants
to uh to parties like mintable which decided
to build a nft marketplace uh we gave grants to
people like pillar protocol which decided to build
a maker like like system so we give grant so that
other people can build because not everything can
be built by us same for uh poly data extends super
data as well because again yes we could have built
this whole system ourselves but then it would have
taken much longer it would have taken uh we have
taken much more risk and then if we had a party
that um again on it is a unfortunately it came
in a bad state right now because of the hack but
they were one of the parties that had the right
middleware that could essentially plug in plug
and play and that made life simpler for everyone
so again if not polygon it would be some someone
else it's like why not go and build a chain link
infrastructure yes you could go and build a chain
link infrastructure but if there's something that
already available why not just plug into that
to make your life easier and so that you could
focus on some things that are much more important
from our side our goal has been to sort of seed
projects or insert ourselves into projects that
can potentially create tentacles for
example once we when we gave grants to
uh switcho the idea was to have decks and
once we had the decks very clearly and very
soon after what we saw afterwards we saw 20
odd projects launching on sale swap so that's
kind of our role our role is to plant seeds the
right seats at the right place so that others can
hopefully build things around that but yeah
we can't build everything ourselves that's not
in the same way theme foundation could not have
built everything that's being built on ethereum
today themselves that is that is something that
you can't do no absolutely um you know but a lot
of people are building a lot of similar things
you know whether it's you know d5 protocols
you know sushi swap pancake swap um you know
everything we've spoken about and mentioned so
our final well it's not a final question but one
of the the the last questions from joshua wilford
is what is zilika's plan to gain more visibility
amongst its competition and this actually leads
me to an another point um which i haven't actually
have written down but it just sort of reminds me
of the top of my head a lot of the questions that
came through were with regards to your marketing
so a lot of the community for whatever reason then
they're not necessarily happy about the marketing
so i'd also like you to tell me what
your marketing plans are sure so look
um first thing is uh i do feel that there is
a lot of there's a lot of noise in the space
and and you have to filter know you know you have
to fill the facts out of that noise in many ways
uh just to give an example right um
you know when we launched uh our decks
self swap and we launched i mean which is the team
that's building this they launched the the decks
when i was interacting with the community it was
very apparent to me that many people in the silica
community obviously the whole ether and the old
bitcoin but they had never used unison before they
had never used curve before they had never used
one inch before and that made me think that there
are definitely a lot of people in the ethereum
space today who hold if they even hold probably
15 20 other assets but they are they have never
used any single gap on ethereum and that's
mind-blowing because then all you're doing is
you're selling tokens and not doing nothing else
and that needs to change so our approach
has been to be able to sort of improve
upon that so and and we saw that result
very quickly for example in zlswap case
uh i was quite surprised to see that uh the
number of people the number of unique addresses
interacting with zil swap on a daily basis
which probably four times higher than
the number of people interacting with you know
curve which is a stable coin decks on ethereum
and that gives you a sense that uh there's a
huge gap between you know projects being used
and projects being being you know in the news
all the time and our our you know focus has
always been to attract more and more people and
convert these token holders into users in some way
and i'm glad that in looking at the numbers
it's very clear to me that that's happening
now uh now coming back to the to the marketing
sort of angle you know marketing is a very
broad term and in in the blockchain community one
because it is it's something that everyone seems
to understand uh you know it's very difficult for
people to understand starting is very difficult
for people to understand a pollinate hack but
it's it's easy to see the impact of marketing
very very very quickly i still remember the
days you know a couple of uh you know when
in in i would say in 2017 or rather in 2018 we had
seen um you know ethereum and bitcoin going really
down up to a point where there was trading at
around 100 or 200 at some point uh there was a lot
of chatter in the ethereum community as well and
say look we need to build uh marketing dolls to
be able to you know push ethereum's narrative and
push ethereum's uh you know benefits and attract
more people towards ethereum and i do feel that um
there is uh if you look at the metrics and there
are different metrics you can measure marketing
right you could look at your committee growth so
you could look at how many people are new people
are joining your twitter community how many new
people are joining the reddit community and that
has constantly been increasing and then there is
angle of this price and exposure right which is
of course when the price goes up everyone wants
to see and wants to be a part of that ecosystem
that's built that's being uh you know marketed
so there's a lot of effort being put into in from
different angles one obviously around making sure
that the theme the silica committee that that
we have around across telegram twitter reddit
keeps on expanding and our numbers show that it
does uh is is it indeed expanding we have seen
in literally in the last six to eight months the
number of projects being built on silk has grown
tremendously you know uh you know so after zoo
swap we have seen more than 20 45 projects being
built over a period of one week or two weeks
and that's a sign that there are people who are
interested in building unzelican through that uh
it comes there comes the network effect because
once you have a project building on silica that
creates the own network effect they have their
own ecosystem and that creates a much broader
narrative of course you know we are also we know
where we lack we know where uh we can improve
and one area is of course influential marketing
that's something that we have to focus on and
that's why we are here yeah absolutely um we
also have a lot of conversation about solana uh i
mean just you don't need to answer this straight
away but i mean somebody just said you know look
what solana are doing that they're doing better
marketing apparently but just in terms of solana
um this will be yeah in terms of solana someone is
asking don't you think solana has taken advantage
um or has taken the advantage that zilliqa has not
in terms of technology but in terms of adoption
and projects built on it how do you intend to
reclaim this advantage so do you think your
advantage has been taken yeah so look um
literally i think uh yesterday someone said uh
oh solano has a hundred x more dabs than silicon
that's not true yeah you know that's not true uh
and then i said look this is not true and then
it's okay maybe i put an extra zero there and and
even that's not true uh you know it's it's it's of
course it's about visibility it's about exposure
but if you if you count the number of daps if
you count the number of users select actually
stands at number five number seven in terms
of blockchain that's actually being used today
and what i've been what i mean by being used is
a number of people who are interacting with the
dapps today on silica number of people who are
you know who are who are sending transactions
on silica and the number of transactions
that the network processes on a daily basis i'm
not talking about the capacity the network can
process but the network i'm talking about the the
the number of transactions that network receives
on a daily basis and that's quite high so if you
look at those numbers it's very clear that you
know zelika stats are number five number seven
across all across all platforms out there so yes
uh you know there could be uh and this some that
we have been working on to to improve the exposure
but uh in terms of advantage i think we have seen
that a lot of you know ethereum for example it
does it does around a million transactions per
day today uh and and it's very clear that uh
dynasty and polychain polygon do a little
bit more right now but uh most chains out
there they do no more than four thousand to five
thousand transactions per day and that's the sad
reality and zelika actually does much better
so um i do feel that yes there is there could
be some work around marketing but if you look at
the real numbers uh zilliqa is not far behind uh
behind many other chains out there including
including some of the popular ones out there
so just as a last final question for you um what
is zilika's vision and what is the main thing
that you are trying to achieve and by which point
do you think that could happen look again i've
probably said this a couple of times but i do feel
that there is a huge gap between token holders
and end users so there are token holders who have
never used any of the dapps and i'm talking about
ethereum even ethereum you know token holders so
it's very clear to me that there is there needs to
be change you need we need to build products
that these token holders can actually go and
use because in this you can't have a platform
which has a million token holders but five users
there's no point in building such a
change you need to be able to have
convert your token holders into users uh so
in ethereum's case roughly speaking around
one percent of i mean less than outside one
percent of token holders actually are users
silica on the other hand even though it
has a much smaller community compared to
the computer ethereum the conversion rate is
actually much higher to around five percent
and the idea is to push that even even further so
i think if we can and this is kind of our mission
is to able to convert our token holders into users
and again i think it's not just should be our our
mission but should be i think generally speaking
should be the mission of of the entire space
uh space where we have to not just say okay look
here's the token you can invest in and then uh
you know put your you know assets and binance
or some exchange audio or your ledger wallet
and then forget about what's happening on the
chain we need to be able to build apps that are
easy for people to use for example if you look
if you look at uni swap and and make a dial if
you're not deep into ethereum space you need to be
have to watch a one hour video from your favorite
influencer to be able to use that use that dab
you can't just download like a traditional app
you can't just go an app store download that
app and be able to use it you can't do that
today and that complexity has to go and there's
something that we're trying to focus on as well
yeah i think that user experience is the most
important thing in this community um you know
having a real use case behind tokens um you know
i certainly agree with you it took me a while to
wrap my head around you know uni swap and pancake
swap and even the i've been using the bridge
between ethereum and binance recently and you
know it takes time to wrap your head around these
things so i think making that user experience as
easy as possible is so so important um so yeah no
absolutely and i'm excited to see how it goes but
amer i want to thank you so much it's been such a
pleasure um having you and having you on the show
i know it's been such a while since you've spoken
so it's been very educational for me to see
where you guys are up to thank you very much
for inviting me over yeah absolute pleasure
and i want to thank everybody for tuning in
um you have a very interesting community i've
been reading the live chats um there's a lot of
jokes in there so it's been amazing to see
how that goes so yeah thank you everybody
for tuning in and america thank you so much for
coming on thank you very much have a good day